อ่ะนะสวัสดีครับถ้าพี่อาร์ตี้เยี่ยม
สวัสดีนักเรียนครับสวัสดีครับ
นิทานนักเรียนกลับมาเรียนภาษาไทยกับ
เพียร์ตีและน้องเรียมมีค่ะวันนี้เรามา
เรียนภาษาไทยกันนะครับวันที่เท่าไหร่ครับ
วันนี้
วันนี้หมดที่ 5 วันนี้วันที่ 5 ใช่ไหม
ครับนี่วันที่ 5 วันที่ 5 เป็นวันอะไร
ครับวันนี้เป็นไงว่า
ศุกร์วันศุกร์หน้าวันศุกร์ที่ 555 วัน
ศุกร์ที่ 5 แล้วเดือนอะไรครับเดือน
พฤศจิกายนเดือน
พฤศจิกายนอ่ะปีปีพตอะไรครับ
ปีคศ 2000  21
2021 นะครับ 5 แล้วปีพ.ศมีอะไรครับ
พ.ศ
2506  14 ค่ะปีพศ
2564 ว้าวมาเรียนภาษาไทยกันแล้วอ่ะตอน
นี้ตอนนี้ที่เรามาเรียนกันเรามาเรียนกัน
กี่โมงครับตอนนี้เออวันนี้
บ่าย 4 โมงกี่โมงกี่โมง
สิบหรือยัง
ยังก้าวหน้ากินพี่
04:09
เป็น 16:00 นเย็น
16:00 น
4:00 นค่ะ 4 โมงเย็นเราจะไปไหนกันดีไป
ไหนกันไปไหนกัน 16:00 นน่า
เราจะไปปิกนิกอ๋อ
ไปปิคนิคกันหน้าไปปิกนิกน่าเดี๋ยววันนี้
เราไปปิกนิกนะครับนี่นี่หน้าเราไปพริกอัน
มีใครไปปิกนิกกับเราบ้างครับวันนี้หน้ามี
ใครไปปิกนิกกับเราบ้าง
มีแม่อ้ามีแม่นี่มีแม่มีใครอีกครับมีพ่อ
อีกห้อน่ะพ่อก็ไปปิกนิกแม่ก็ไปปิคนิค 5
แล้วมีใครไปปิกนิกอีกครับ
มีลูกชายมีลูกชายลูกชายไปปิกนิกหน้าแล้ว
มีใครอีกครับ
มีลูกสาวมีลูกสาวลูกสาวไปปิกนิกอ่ะอ่า
แล้วก็มีพี่อาร์ตี้แล้วก็มีเห็นห้องเรียว
แล้วก็มีนักเรียนไปปิกนิกกันน้ำ We  are
a  b  of ไปปิคนิคในเขาก็ไปปิกนิก
นักเรียนชอบไปให้ปิดแค่ 5 นะครับตอนนี้
ตอนนี้คุณพ่อ
คุณแม่
ลูกชายแล้วก็ลูกสาวไปปิกนิกที่ไหนครับไป
ปิกนิกที่ไหนครับ
ในสวนอ๋ออ๋อในสวนเองในสวนในสวนคืออะไร
ครับไม่สวนคืออะไร
สวนคือที่ที่มีต้นไม้
ที่มีต้นไม้มีต้นไม้อ๋อมีต้นไม้เยอะอ่ามี
ต้นไม้เยอะเลยนี่มีต้นไม้หน้าเราเรียก
ครับสนามหญ้าอ๋ออ๋อมีเสน่ห์คุณย่านี่มี
สนามหญ้าแล้วก็มีต้นไม้เรียกว่าสวนหน้า
เป็นสงขลามีต้นไม้มีสนามยากเครียดที่ชอบ
ชอบสวนชอบต้นไม้อ่ะน้องเรียมชอบต้นไม้ไหม
ครับ
ชอบค่ะพี่อั้มก็ชอบ
ให้ 5 มีต้นไม้สีเขียวอ่ะเฮียตีชอบต้นไม้
สีเขียว
เนื้อ
หาแล้ววันนี้วันนี้วันนี้คุณพ่อลูกชายลูก
สาวคุณแม่ก็ไปปิคนิคกันในสวนนะอ่า
เช้าค่ะวันนี้คุณพ่อใส่เสื้อสีขาวอ่ะ
เรียงก็ใส่เสื้อสีขาวอ่ะนักเรียนใส่เสื้อ
สีขาวคุณพ่อก็ใส่เสื้อสีขาวเองคุณพ่อใส่
เสื้อสีขาววันนี้ไม่ใช่เสื้อแขนยาวแล้ว
คุณพ่อใส่เสื้อแขนสั้น
หาคุณพ่อเสื้อแขนสั้นนะครับอ่าแขนปั้น
น้องเรียมน้องเรียมก็ใส่เสื้อแขนสั้นอ่า
อะไรค่ะมีอาตี้พีอาร์ตี้ก็ใส่เสื้อแขน
สั้นเหมือนกันนี่ไอ้เสื้อแขนสั้น
แล้วเสื้อของพี่อาร์ตี้สีอะไรค่ะเสื้อของ
พี่อาร์ตี้สี
ม่วง
5 เมียนใส่เสื้อสีม่วงอ่ะครับ
แล้วลูกชายวันนี้วันนี้ลูกชายใส่เสื้อสี
อะไรครับ
วันนี้ลูกชายอ่าใส่เสื้อสีแดง
ใส่เสื้อสีแดงอ่ะเหมือนปากกาของน้องเรียม
ประการน้องเรียมก็สีแดงลูกชายก็ใส่เสื้อ
สีแดง
อ่ะแล้ววันนี้ครับลูกสาวล่ะคะเทียบสาวใส่
เสื้อสีอะไรครับนักเรียน
นักเรียนคิดว่าลูกสาวใส่เสื้อสีอะไรครับ
ฮ่าๆพี่อ้ะตี้คิดว่าลูกสาวใส่เสื้อสี
เหลือง
หน้าค่ะเหนือคิดว่าลูกสาวใส่เสื้อสี
เหลืองเหมือนปากกาเลยปากกาน้องเรียมก็สี
เหลืองๆแล้วลูกสาวก็ใส่เสื้อแขน
สั้นเหมือนกันสาวก็ใส่เสื้อแขนสั้นหน้า
คุณพ่อก็ใส่เสื้อแขนสั้นลูกชายก็ใส่เสื้อ
แขนสั้นๆหัวหน้า x  f เสื้อคุณแม่ล่ะคะ
เสื้อคุณแม่เสื้อคุณแม่มีแขนมั้ยน้อง
เรียมที่ไม่เห็นแขนเสื้อคุณแม่ไม่
เห็นแขนเออค่ะอ๋อเสื้อคุณแม่ไม่มีแขน
ให้มีแขน
ไม่มีแขนเรียกว่าอะไรครับเรียกว่าเสื้อ
แขนกุดขอเสื้อแขนกุดเสื้อแขนกุดไม่มีแขน
หน้าไม่มีแขนอ้าแบบนี้นี่เสื้อแขนกุดไม่
มีแขนเอาโอเค
อ้าวันนี้ทุกคนไปปิกนิกแล้วตีเห็น
คุณแม่คุณแม่ถืออะไรครับถืออ่ะขอให้ขออีก
อะไรแม่ถือ
ตะกร้า
ตะกร้าตะกร้าอ๋อถือแตกปลาที่ใส่ใส่ของมา
ใส่ของไปค่ะ
ปิกนิกอ๋ออ๋อคุณแม่ถือตะกร้าว้าวถือ
ตะกร้าใบใหญ่เลยอ่ะเฮียตีก็เห็นคุณพ่อคุณ
พ่อก็ถือเหมือนกันคุณพ่อถืออะไรครับคุณ
พ่อถือถุงอ๋อ
ถือถุง opp ถุงใบใหญ่อ่าโอเคไปใหญ่ในถุง
ก็ใส่ของปิคนิคเหมือนกันเออใส่กรอกปิกนิก
ว้าวแล้วลูกชายลูกสาวถืออะไรครับอ่าก็ไม่
ได้ถึง
ไม่ได้ถือลูกสาวไม่ได้ถือลูกชายก็ไม่ได้
ถือ
คุณพ่อคุณพ่อถือ
ถุงคุณแม่อ้าโหถ้าคุณแม่ก็ถือตะกร้าโอเค
คุณแม่กำลังทำอะไรอยู่ครับคุณแม่ทำแบบนี้
คุณแม่ที่คุณแม่ชี้กำลังชี้ชี้ว่าเดี๋ยว
เราอ่ะไปนั่งตรงโน้นใช่ไหมไปนั่งตรงโน้น
อ่าคุณแม่บอกบอกลูกลูกเราไปนั่งตรงนู้น
อ่ะโอเคไปครับเราไปนั่ง
นี่ตอนนี้เครามานั่งปิคนิคแล้วใข้ในรูป
นี้น้องเรียมเห็นอะไรบ้างครับเห็น
พ่อ
คุณแม่ถอดรองเท้า
โอ้คุณแม่ถอดรองเท้านี่รองเท้าตอนนี้คุณ
แม่ไม่ได้ใส่รองเท้าใช่ไหมไม่ได้ใส่รอง
เท้าไม่ได้ใส่รองเท้าเราพูดว่าถอดรองเท้า
เหรออ่าพูดว่าถอดรองเท้าคุณแม่ถอดรองเท้า
เอ้อโอ้เฮียตีก็เห็นเห็นลูกชายลูกชายลูก
ชายก็
ถอดรองเท้านะเลยครับแล้วลูกสาวลูกสาวถอด
รองเท้าไหมครับ
ถอดรองเท้าค่ะลูกสาวก็ถอดรองเท้าหน้าโอเค
แล้วน้องเรียมเห็นอะไรอีกครับพี่ก็เรียง
เห็นแก้วน้ำอ๋ออ๋อมีแก้วน้ำนี่นิแก้ว
แก้วน้ำหน้าแก้วน้ำอันนี้แก้วน้ำของใคร
ครับ
แก้วน้ำของคุณแม่อ๋ออ๋อแก้วน้ำของคุณแม่
นะครับอ่ามีแก้วน้ำอยู่ตรงนี้อ้าแก้วน้ำ
แก้วนี้ของใครครับ
เรียงคิดว่า
ของคุณพ่อเป็นแก้วน้ำของคุณพ่อเคนิแก้ว
น้ำของคุณพ่ออันนี้แก้วน้ำของคุณแม่อ่ะ
แล้วแก้วน้ำของลูกชายอยู่ไหนครับ
อยู่ข้างๆอ๋ออยู่มีอยู่ตรงนี้ใช่ไหมครับ
มีแก้วน้ำของลูกชายอ่าแล้วอันนี้แยกน้ำ
ของใครครับวันนี้เจ้าน้ำของลูกสาว
เต็มแก้วน้ำของลูกสาวโอเคอ้าแล้วแก้วน้ำ
ของของน้องเรียมอยู่ไหนครับ
แก้วน้ำของเรียมอยู่นี่ค่ะอ๋ออ่อนี่แก้ว
น้ำของน้องเรียมานี่แก้วน้ำของแอปที่ดี
แนวหน้าของที่อาตี้โอเค
นะๆเฮียตีเห็นเห็นอันนี้อันนี้อะไรครับ
อันนี้
ขวดน้ำค่ะอ๋ออันนี้เป็นครูขวดเป็นขวดไม่
ใช่แก้วใช่ไหมค่ะนี่เป็นขวดไม่ควรก็มีมี
มีน้ำน้ำอ๋ออ๋อไม่ขวดมีน้ำเราเรียกว่าขวด
น้ำ
มีขวดน้ำเจ๊นิขวดน้ำมีแก้วน้ำแล้วมีอะไร
อีกครับพี่
ว่ามันฝรั่งมัน
พ่อมัน
อยู่ไหนครับ
ทอดอยู่ข้างๆขวดน้ำหอมอยู่ข้างๆขวดน้ำอัน
นี้ใช่ไหมครับนี่มันฝรั่งทอดเคแอลเอามัน
ฝรั่งทอดกินกินได้ใช่ไหมครับถ้าได้ยินมัน
ฝรั่งทอดหน้าแล้วตอนนี้ลูกสาวกำลังกิน
อะไรครับ
ลูกสาวกำลังกินเตรียมคิดว่าทอดไหมใช่ไหม
ไม่ใช่ไม่ใช่ลูกสาวไม่ได้กินมันฝรั่งพ่อ
ลูกสาวกินกินอะไรครับ
คิดเรียงคิดว่าว่าลูกสาวกินข้าว
พี่เชอรี่อ๋ออ๋อ Cherry  Cherry  Cherry
เป็นผลไม้ในรูปสีแดงแล้วก็มีขั้วแบบนี้นะ
เชอรี่ใช่ไหม Cherry
สีแดงโอเคอ่าน้องเรียมชอบกินเชอร์รี่ไหม
ครับ
เรียมชอบอ๋ออ๋อนี่ค่ะอ๋อเหมือนลูกสาวลูก
อ่อนลูกสาวก็กินเชอรี่เจ๊
เพียงตี้ครับผมเห็นเป็นดิ
แซนด์วิช
แซนด์วิชอยู่นี่ครับมีมีแฟน with
มีแซนด์วิชนี่เพียบที่ชอบอยู่แซนวิชไหมคะ
อ้าพี่อาร์ตี้ชอบกินอาแซนวิชใช่ครับหน้า
มีแซนวิชอยู่ในจานตรงนี้อ่าแซนวิชอยู่ใน
จานตะเค
หาแล้วมีอะไรอีกครับตอนนี้อันนี้เฮียตี
เห็นสีแดงๆนี้สีแดงแดงนี้คืออะไรครับสี
แดงคืออะไรครับ
เสื่อค่ะเสื่อ
เสื่อเสื่อออกเป็นเสื่อที่ทุกคนนั่งคุณ
แม่นั่งบนเสื่อลูกชายลูกชายก็นั่งบนเสื่อ
น้าาลูกสาวก็นั่งบนเสื่อ
คุณพ่อก็นั่งคนบุญเผื่อแล้วพี่อ่ะ
พี่ตอนนี้ล่ะคะที่กำลังนั่งบนอะไรเฮียตี
ไม่ได้นั่งเสื่อเตียงที่นั่งบนเก้าอี้
ครับ
นี้บนเก้าอี้ที่คือเก้าอี้ของเบียร์ตี้
เรียงก็เหมือนกันค่ะอ๋อ
เตรียมก็นั่งนั่งบนเก้าอี้
แต่คุณแม่คุณแม่นั่งบนเสื่ออะลูกชายนั่ง
บนเสือแถว K
ว้าวแล้ว 5 เดี๋ยวหลังจากที่เรานั่งบน
เสื่อแล้วเรากินแสน with เรากินมันปะหลัง
กินน้ำแล้วเราทำอะไรอีกครับ
เราก็จะไปวิ่งเล่นอ่าเราไปวิ่งเล่นกันนะ
อ่ะตอนนี้ลูกชายลูกชายวิ่งเล่นใช่ไหมครับ
ใช้ค่ะลูกสาวก็
โอ๊ยลูกสาวก็วิ่งเล่นเล่นเหมือนกันอ่ะลูก
ชายกับลูกสาววิ่งเล่นกันเห้ยแล้วคุณพ่อ
คุณพ่อทำอะไรครับตอนนี้คุณพ่อนอนอ๋อได้
สบายนอนนอนนอนอยู่บอล
เสื้อ
นอนอยู่บนเสื่อคุณแม่ล่ะครับคุณแม่ทำอะไร
คุณแม่ก็
นอนอ่า
นอนอยู่บนเสื่อเสื่อคุณพ่อก็นอนอยู่บน
เสื่อแต่ลูกชายไม่ได้นอนลูกชายวิ่งวิ่ง
อยู่
ลูกสาว
ก็ไม่ได้นอนไม่ได้สาววิ่ง 5 ลูกสาวกับลูก
ชายวิ่งอยู่หน้าตอนนี้อ่ะ
และก็ผม
ครับผมน่าสนุกมาปิกนิกน่าสนุกจังเลยโอเค
เองเดี๋ยวนะตอนนี้พี่อาร์ตี้เห็นว่า
เขานอนและ
นั่งวิ่งเล่นกันแล้วแล้วอันนี้ตอนนี้เขา
ทำอะไรกันครับ
อ๋อเขาเก็บของขอ
เก็บของเก็บของเทียบกันคิดมากเขา
กำลังทำเค้กอยู่นี่เหมือนเค้กเลยใช้เค้ก
ไหมครับนี้เขา Cherry  Lee ใส่ลงไปบนเค้ก
อานี่ลูกสาวยังกินกินเชอรี่อยู่สาวที่
injury ได้
ดีแล้วลูกชายก็เอาเชอรี่ใส่ลงบนเค้กจ้า
น่าใส่ลงในจานอ้าใช่ครับ
โอเคแล้วคุณแม่คุณแม่ก็ยัง
คุณแม่เลี้ยงดอกคนอีก full นอนนอนดูลูก
สาวแน่นอนดูคุณพ่อคุณพ่อถือจานถือจานใส่
ใส่
โอเค
น้าอา
ในรูปนี้อ่ามีอะไรอีกครับเห็นอะไรในรูป
นี้อีกอ่ะ
โห
ครับ
ทุกคนกำลังนั่งอยู่นั่งอยู่บนเสื่อแต่คุณ
แม่คุณแม่ไม่นั่งแม่นครนอนเนื้อไปหาทราย
ครับ
อ้าวคุณพ่อก็มองดูเค้กคุณพ่อมองดูคุณพ่อ
เริ่มอยากกินนะอยากกินอยากกินเค้กอ่ะ
ฟ้าๆแล้วพี่อาร์ตี้นะคะเที่ยวที่ชอบกิน kr
ตีกชกินพี่ชอบกินทุกอย่างเลยอ่ะอ่ะชอบกิน
เค้กชอบกินแซนวิชน่ะชอบกินเชอรี่ด้วยนะ
ครับอาหารแล้วเดี๋ยวเรากินเค้กเสร็จแล้ว
เราช่วยกันเก็บเก็บของใส่ตะกร้าหน้าเก็บ
จานใส่ถุงอายเดี๋ยวเสร็จแล้วเราจะได้กลับ
บ้านกันน่ะซินิคเสร็จแล้วเราก็กลับบ้าน
กันนะครับถ้านับแล้ววันนี้อ้าวันนี้เรา
ทุกคนไปปิคนิคกันสนุกไหมครับนักเรียนสนุก
ไหมครับนักเรียนได้เรียนรู้ได้เรียนรู้
อะไรบ้างครับวันนี้หน้าขี้ comment
เขียน Comment ให้พี่อาร์ตี้กับน้ำเลียม
รู้หน่อยว่านักเรียนได้เรียนอะไรกันบ้าง
วันนี้ไหมครับใครค่ะวันนี้เรี่ยมกับพี่
อาร์ตี้ไปปิกนิกมาสนุกมากๆได้กินได้กิน
แซนวิชกินเชอรี่กินเขตด้วย 555  ka ขาย
วิ่งเล่นด้วยได้วิ่งเล่นน่ะแล้วก็ได้นอน
นอนบนเสื่อใช่มั้ยฮาๆสบายนอนในสวนในสวนมี
ต้นไม้
ไปหาไม่ส่วนก็มีสนามหญ้า
ถ้าไม่มีสนามหญ้าด้วยแล้วเดี๋ยวคราวหน้า
คราวหน้าที่อ่ะตีกับน้องเรียมจะพานัก
เรียนไปเที่ยวที่ไหนนะครับกลับมาเรียน
ภาษาไทยกับเพียงตีกับน้องเรียนด้วยกัน
คราวหน้าครับหน้าโอเคแล้วรอรอนะคะเจอกับ
เที่ยวพี่กับเตรียมในคลิปหน้าค่ะเมย์ขอ
ขอบคุณขอบคุณดีค่ะสวัสดีครับนักเรียนอ่ะ
ครับผมขอบคุณครับน้องเรียมขอบคุณครับ
บ๊ายบายนักเรียน
เก็บของเก็บของ